only a sucker wouldn't like tucker cable
news powerhouse tucker carlson's brand
new book is out today on the state of
the media it's called the long slide 30
years in american journalism you can get
it in person uh wherever books are sold
or buy it on tuckercarlson.com he has
that where you can also get a signed
copy tucker joins us right now to talk
about it hi tucker how you doing oh
couldn't be better greg gutfeld
excellent x and i was always a fan of
your writing before i even knew you and
one thing i learned from you once is
that you don't like to write
well nobody likes to write
you have to be defective to like to
write
sit and create something out of nothing
in front of a blank terminal just like
hell yeah but it's reward as you know i
mean you started as a writer too you
still are it's deeply rewarding i'm glad
i've done it i don't want to do too much
more if i can help it yes
but these are all um these are essays
that have been refined in in everything
so it's
aside from the in the long introduction
in which you mention how much you like
al sharpton uh these are all uh
uh older stories correct well yeah but
they're framed by
a reported piece i did which is the
beginning of the book on simon schuster
which published it yes which is one of
the biggest publishers in the world and
long a defender of the freedom of speech
freedom of conscience the free flow of
ideas
dissent the ability to disagree which
has become one of the leading forces of
censorship
in the country killing books because the
democratic party doesn't like the book
so to write the introduction to write
this chapter i interviewed the head of
the company jonathan carp and the new
head of simon schuster of the imprint
who was hired after the george floyd
riots with literally not one day of
experience in the publishing business
and i asked them wait a second you're
one of the biggest publishers in the
world
how did you get to be sensors how did
this happen and had this kind of amazing
conversation i thought they were pretty
honest yeah about their role in it uh it
was nauseating if i'm gonna be totally
blunt with you um but it was certainly
informative yes dana well um so tucker i
first came to know you when you were
writing these longer magazine pieces in
the well to say in the late 90s right so
we can we can age ourselves a little bit
and i loved reading your work and i know
that um that you're the reporting part
of it and the interviewing and getting
to know people yeah is also a really
important thing but i still think i
think that youtube it's important for
young people to learn how to write um
what's the most important thing people
can do today like if you're a young
person and you want to be a writer and
you want to kind of be like tucker
carlson how do you
get those skills what's the best way to
learn how to write like this well there
aren't many skills actually
it's a trade not a profession first
don't go to journalism school
you'll meet the worst people in america
and will make you dumber second learn
how to write clear english we have the
you know the biggest language in human
history there are more ways to describe
things in english than any other
language you've got all these words
learn how to use them learn grammar and
learn how to write a clear declarative
sentence subject verb subject verb
repeat after me take out the adjectives
adverbs are your enemy avoid them
read politics in the english language by
george orwell and just learn to write
clearly that's that's the whole check
right there it's not hard
do you miss it at all i mean do you miss
those pieces at all like writing them i
know i'm not writing
well i write every day i write it more
now than i've ever written in my life
but i don't get out of my weird little
cave to talk to other people and i i
definitely miss getting on the road to
faraway places don't mean to monopolize
your time yeah dana sorry please
monopolize the time i'm gonna ask a
really long question now hey hey tucker
um
a little bit like you but not to your
extent i spent a lot of time what we
would call the mainstream media espn or
cnn i'm fascinated by the idea of the
long slide in your experience the media
seems to have changed drastically since
the election of donald trump of the last
five years but was it always there do
you think the attitudes that we are
seeing today were always there in the
media covered up or have they changed
well there's always been that's such a
great question there's always been a
totalitarian instinct on the right
because it's a kind of religious faith
that you know and so the instinct has
been well anyone who disagrees with me
is evil but that was kept in check by
the principles of journalism and
publishing which demanded
open dialogue you had to listen to the
other side you had to allow the other
side to talk that's what you know
liberalism was that that's the basic
enlightenment value is you have to allow
your ideas to be challenged and you get
to challenge the other side's ideas that
evaporated slowly and then quickly just
like bankruptcy it happened over time
and then all at once and you sort of
wake up in this totalitarian environment
where no one's allowed to talk unless
you're repeating a very small set of
slogans and the people in charge of the
business the editors
the publishers the people who run tv
networks are all participating in it
it's like if you're 52 like i am if
you're an aging american it's it's
totally shocking to watch it jessica
okay um so i also loved what you said
about making it quick and dirty when
you're writing i remember getting into
grad school and they said every comment
could be a period and i was like oh
actually that's true
but my question is about uh you know
you've obviously interviewed a ton of
fascinating people both sides of the
aisle who would you most like to
interview again if they would take your
call
oh gosh that's such a great question
there's so many people i mean honestly
i'd like to interview anybody in
democratic leadership i'd like to
interview a democratic congressman no
one will talk to me no one will come on
the show you're a white supremacist
we're not talking to you really no i'm
not i just
i just have different ideas from you why
are you calling me names it's not even
real
just come on and talk to me like a
normal human being you and i talk all
the time have for a long time we
disagree it's not that hard it's fun but
they won't we definitely disagree and
most of the time it's fun i'll talk to
my people i'll try to get you a
congressman
well tucker uh katie pavlich here i have
to admit that i went to journalism
school so i'm sorry to disappoint you
with that but it's fascinating to me
that you were a college your first job
out of college was as a fact checker and
i think that fact-checking has changed
so much in addition to traditional
journalism so i want to get your take on
that but then i also want to know where
we can buy your book because i know that
you have a different strategy
well fact-checking used to require
calling people on the phone and ask them
questions now it entails going to
wikipedia which news flash is not a news
source
wikipedia is another form of propaganda
there's truth on it as there always is
in propaganda but fundamentally it's not
reliable so that's not fact checking
just so you know um the book is on
tuckercarlson.com it's available in all
different kinds of places but the book
is partly about the creeping power of
the tech monopolies
which squelch speech and thought and
freedom and so why not go around them
we're trying
a new version of distribution here um on
our website and we'll see how it works i
hope it does we need alternatives to
what we have i would say that
well best of luck
thanks so much all right tucker i will
can i ask him one more question is there
anybody you uh that you're reading now
in journalism that you really like
oh there's so many on sub stack right
and i probably shouldn't say it because
some are like refugees from the left and
i don't want to further discredit them
by admitting i read them good point but
there are a bunch of people i know you
read them i gave up my new york times
and washington post descriptions because
it's just garbage it's like stupid and
boring yeah except the o bits which i
still like and dana sends it to me but
other than that i spend my money on sub
stack and i'm really happy about it
there's some really
interesting writers out there right now
and they're all on something
amazing all right tucker thank you so
much his new book the long slide 30
years in american journalism is on sale
now straight ahead reading and writing
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else